جاؤوها بحثا عن فرص جديده وهاهم يغادرونها
للنجاه بحياتهم نحو عشره الاف شخص من
خمسين دوله حول العالم تم اجلائهم حتى
الان منهم 2250 من جنسيات مختلفه نقل بحرا
من ميناء بورتسودان الى بناء جده في
السعوديه
اكثر من 1500 مواطن مصري والمئات من
المواطنين العرب عاشوا سفر الجلاء الاصعب
اكثر من الف كيلو متر بحافلات نقلتهم الى
الحدود المصريه عائشه شديد
في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه ولا مش حنلقاه
البري لحد عبرك عشان دي عطبره لحد
السمكاتها اخذنا يومين
وسجلنا هنا والله البحريه السعوديه بارك
الله فيهم
400 فرنسي ومئه الماني وغيرهم من الدول
الاجنبيه نقل جوا من مطار عسكري قرب
الخرطوم الى مطار جيبوتي بعثه دبلوماسيه
امريكيه وروسيه واسيويه وجدت هي الاخرى
السبيلا للنجاه من حرب السودان معظم هؤلاء
النازحين كانوا محركا نهضه ماموله في
السودان اطباء ومهندسون ومعلمون قالوا
عجله تنميه تعثرت
فقيدوا خارج الحدود لكن ماذا عن
السودانيين الراغبين في النجاه بحياتهم
لقد وقعوا فريسه تجار
الحربات عامه في التساكر
زمان لما
35 ليله
وكل يوم
الشبان ان تذكره الحافله وصلت الى 350
دولار سوق حرب سوداء بدات تلوح في الافق
نشاهد لعائلات نزحت الى تشاد بحثا عن امن
وغذاء تذكر بالسنوات مجاعه وجفاف ولكن هذه
المره السبب البشر
وليس قله المطر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات